Що спільного у трави і туалетного паперу?
На перший погляд - нічого.
А от німецькі школярі придумали, як зробити
з трави туалетний папір!  І зробили.
Йоанна Бауманн побачила в документальному фільмі,
як із трави виробляють картон.
Геніально: трава -  це екологічно чиста регіональна сировина,
яка ще й швидко відновлюється,
одумали п'ятеро одинадцятикласників гімназії в німецькому містечку Бад Гоннеф.
І взялися за роботу.
Проаналізувавши ринок, постачальників трав'яних гранул
та кількість потенційних покупців,
у школярів швидко з'явилася ідея виробляти з трави
саме туалетний папір.
Адже туалетний папір - це те, від чого не можна просто відмовитися.
Від одноразових стаканчиків для кави, наприклад, відмовитися відносно легко,
а від туалетного паперу - ні.
Свій бізнес-проект школярі розробляли для участі в конкурсі "бізнес-скул"
або "школа бізнесу" на загальнонімецькому рівні.
І їхній туалетний папір побив усіх конкурентів.
Проект визнали таким, що можна просто одразу втілювати в життя.
Але головне - він екологічний.
Мені здається, це круто, що ми таким чином можемо запобігти вирубці
шестисот тисяч дерев, які щороку в Німеччині , по суті,
змиваються в туалет.
Якщо цей папір таки з'явиться, я б сама його купувала.
Поки що існує лише ось цей прототип.
Якщо школярі таки вирішать виробляти його у промислових масштабах,
то упаковка з восьми рулонів коштуватиме 3 євро 99  центів.
Це в середньому на 50 центів дорожче, ніж звичайний папір.
Утім на 2 євро дешевше, ніж інші екологічні альтернативи.
Ми також зможемо цим заробляти гроші,
наприклад, "точки беззбитковості" ми досягнемо на п'ятнадцятому місяці,
якщо продамо сто сім тисяч упаковок.
Школярі сподіваються на дохід у 3 мільйони євро вже за 5 років.
Вони покроково прорахували і реалізували свій бізнес-план -
аж до договорів з мережами супермаркетів.
Щоправда, поки лише в теорії.
Є дві великі переваги у такому проекті. Перша - потрібно мати дуже багато навичок:
вміти робити розрахунки, мати технічне уявлення про виробництво продукту
вміти його презентувати, відповідати на питання.
Такий проект дуже всебічний.
Навряд чи якийсь урок може бути настільки всебічним.
Виробництво туалетного паперу з трави відносно просте:
траву переробляють та пресують в трав'яні гранули,
а ті подають у машини для виробництва паперу.
Тож, про неекологічний папір, який завдає непоправної шкоди лісам,
можна просто забути.
Та поки в юних винахідників у планах - закінчити школу.
Випускні іспити вже через рік.